[Música]
chile inició el despliegue militar en la
frontera con Perú y Bolivia la medida
estará vigente Por 90 días y busca
controlar la migración irregular hacia
su territorio los uniformados tendrán
prohibido utilizar armas de fuego a
menos que sea completamente necesario
está en Brasil John Kerry el enviado
especial de Estados Unidos para el clima
del funcionario se reunirá con el
presidente Luis Ignacio alulada Silva
con quien espera alcanzar un acuerdo
para proteger la selva amazónica que ha
presentado cifras significativas de
deforestación
el gobierno estadounidense dijo que no
hay conclusión definitiva ni un consenso
sobre los orígenes del Coby 19 luego de
que el Wall Street journal le informara
que el departamento de energía había
sugerido que el virus surgió tras una
fuga de un laboratorio chino tenemos
informes desde Washington
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz iniciamos en
Chile este lunes empezó el despliegue
militar en la frontera norte para
enfrentar la crisis migratoria la medida
que tiene una vigencia de 90 días se da
en respuesta a los reclamos de las
autoridades locales que por varios años
han pedido que se tomen acciones que
frenen el aumento de la entrada
irregular de migrantes a su territorio
el decreto Establece que los militares
pueden hacer uso de su armamento de
dotación solo en caso de ser agredidos
con armas letales la ministra del
interior Carolina tojah llegó hasta la
comuna de colchani ubicada en la zona
fronteriza y aseguró que la
militarización es solo el primer paso
para responder a los desafíos que
presenta esta problemática previamente
hablamos con Javier García alcalde de
esta comuna quien saludó la medida pero
aseguró que esta no va a solucionar en
su totalidad el problema
es suficiente porque esta medida por sí
sola no va a solucionar el problema de
la migración irregular ya que una vez
controlada a las personas en su
identidad revisada sus equipajes de
todas maneras aquellos que no son por
ejemplo bolivianos van a ingresar de
manera irregular a nuestro país puesto
que la figura de la reconducción O la
devolución al país de procedencia en
este caso no está operando porque el
vecino país de Bolivia no tiene la
voluntad de recibirlos no así el país
vecino de Perú que sí lo recibe y por
otro lado necesitamos medidas
ejemplares como la expulsión
administrativa masiva porque sería una
señal de ese incentivo para que más
migrantes que se encuentren hoy día en
Bolivia en Perú en Colombia ingresen por
este sector que es de muy difícil
control ya que tenemos 130 kilómetros de
frontera con Bolivia y Lamentablemente
las temperaturas también son muy
extremas
vamos a Colombia en una sorpresiva y
breve a locución al presidente Gustavo
Petro anunció la salida de varios de sus
ministros en medio de las discrepancias
entre los miembros de su gabinete por la
reforma a la salud se trata del ministro
de Educación Alejandro Gaviria a la
ministra del deporte María Isabel
Urrutia y la ministra de cultura
Patricia ariza durante su discurso el
mandatario dijo claro que no va a
renunciar a sus reformas la decisión del
presidente Petro marca la primera crisis
ministerial en solo seis meses después
de haber llegado al poder
las reformas necesitan debate en la
sociedad
consenso en el gobierno y después de
aprobadas por el congreso y por la
sociedad misma necesitan mucha
determinación para aplicarlas este
gobierno del cambio no Va a renunciar a
reformar para mejorar la salud las
pensiones y las condiciones laborales
justas para todas los colombianos y
colombianas en Brasil el gobierno de
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva recibió a
John Carrey enviado especial del
gobierno de Estados Unidos para el clima
una visita que busca alcanzar un acuerdo
sobre Cómo proteger la selva amazónica Y
cómo recaudar fondos para los diferentes
programas de protección la visita tiene
el lugar cuando han pasado cuatro años
consecutivos en los que las cifras de
deforestación aumentaron
significativamente debido a las
políticas laxas del gobierno del
expresidente jael bolsonaro
es una buena noticia para la protección
de la amazonía brasileña este lunes el
enviado especial para la protección del
medio ambiente de Estados Unidos John
Kerry llegó a Brasil para reunirse con
el gobierno de Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva su objetivo principal recaudar
fondos para conservar el mayor bosque
del mundo algo crucial en estos momentos
Kerry y yo Tuvimos una conversación
preliminar sobre los temas que serán
objetivo de una empresa conjunta
anunciada
cuando tengamos el resultado del trabajo
conjunto en temas como el clima el fondo
de la amazonía O la cooperación de
Brasil Estados Unidos
lo anunciaremos
Y es que la lucha contra la
deforestación y la protección de la
amazonía fue una de las promesas de
campaña de Lula que su gobierno parece
estar decidido a cumplir Para ello el
presidente ya anunció que planeaba pedir
ayuda a otros países ricos como ya he
hecho con Noruega o Alemania y como hizo
durante su visita a Estados Unidos a
principios de este mes
sentí una gran voluntad por parte del
presidente biden de participar en la
creación de un fondo en el que
participen todos los países
desarrollados del mundo para que
intentemos cuidar mejor de nuestro
planeta
un poco más de cariño la razón para
pedir esta ayuda Es que la amazonía es
patrimonio del mundo y cuidarla es una
responsabilidad compartida El Ejecutivo
brasileño ha dejado Claro que siempre
estará Bajo su potestad Pero quiere
intentar reparar al máximo la
deforestación y degradación del bioma
tras años especialmente duros para el
mayor bosque del mundo
en Estados Unidos sigue la discusión
sobre los orígenes del covid 19 luego de
que el periódico de Wall Street journal
informara que el departamento de energía
había concluido que la pandemia
probablemente surgió tras una fuga en un
laboratorio chino ahora el portavoz de
seguridad Nacional de la Casa Blanca
John Kirby dijo que no había conclusión
definitiva ni un consenso en el gobierno
estadounidense sobre los orígenes del
virus desde Washington los detalles con
nuestro corresponsal Cristóbal Vázquez
y el portavoz del Consejo de Seguridad
Nacional de Estados Unidos dijo que el
presidente biden tiene toda la
determinación para encontrar el origen
del Coby 19 que ya ha cobrado la vida
que en Estados Unidos de más de un
millón de personas aseguró desde la casa
blanca que no hay consenso en
administración de biden sobre el origen
del virus esto después de que el
departamento de energía determinara que
el virus se había filtrado de un
laboratorio cerca buján en China pero
que la nueva inteligencia que tenían era
de baja confianza como lo reportó
inicialmente el Walter la explicación de
la filtración la comparte también el FBI
pero no es la misma que la de otras
cuatro agencias gubernamentales en
Estados Unidos que dicen que el origen
fue el resultado de una transmisión
natural de un animal infectado como
también lo sugiere la Organización
Mundial de la Salud al respecto el
gobierno de China rechazó la evaluación
del departamento de energía y dijo que
el origen del virus es un tema
científico que no debe ser politizado
por su parte congresistas en Estados
Unidos le están pidiendo la
administración de biden que
desclasifique entonces la información
que tiene sobre el virus algo que la
Casa Blanca no se comprometió a hacer en
los próximos días
seguimos en Estados Unidos en Florida el
gobernador ron de santis firmó la ley
para que el estado retome el control
administrativo y fiscal del territorio
donde se encuentran los parques Disney
World en Orlando previamente la empresa
del entretenimiento actuaba como
gobierno local lo que le permitía tener
políticas propias y toma de decisiones
de Santi se prepara para presentar su
candidatura a la presidencia tras una
victoria en las legislativas que le ha
dado visibilidad como gobernador y ahora
con esta decisión obtendrá visibilidad a
nivel nacional y lo pondrá en un plano
destacado dentro de la política
republicana
[Música]
mi firma en este proyecto de ley también
impondrá la ley de Florida en esta área
tal como se impone en Universal Estudios
de seaword y todos estos otros lugares y
este proyecto de ley la estructura que
hemos creado en este proyecto de ley
garantizarán que la deuda municipal
acumulada sea pagada por Disney no por
los contribuyentes de Florida estas son
ya sabes décadas de subsidios y
beneficios que se han acumulado para
formar esta poderosa empresa y ahora que
estamos básicamente en igualdad de
condiciones y lo que es bueno para
siward es bueno para Disney y así es
como tiene que ser
esto y cerramos con noticias del fútbol
el jugador argentino Lionel Messi ganó
este lunes su segundo premio de Best al
superar a su compañero de equipo del
París saint-germain kilian mbappé y al
también francés Karim Benzema Messi se
hizo con la mayoría de votos para el
premio la actuación del argentino de 35
años en la pasada Copa del Mundo de
Qatar donde su país logró el tercer
título le valió para recibir el
reconocimiento Este es el segundo premio
de Best que logra Messi en su carrera y
con ello empata a Cristiano Ronaldo y a
Robert lewandowski como los únicos que
han ganado este premio en dos ocasiones
desde el año 2016
[Música]
de esta manera despedimos este
Informativo en frases 24 Gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]